[Music]
how's it going bros my name is peter
pack
welcome to you laugh you donate if i
laugh
i have to donate money to a twitch
streamer
i i did pissed some people off last
video so i want to start up this video
with the
side sad music please
i'm so sorry i did not donate enough
money to the streamers
this time i have a sponsor this week so
i'm gonna donate
a ton of money that's a lie i'll
probably donate a moderate amount but
still
if i laugh i will donate okay i didn't
realize i had to donate
thousands of dollars okay i'm sorry i
forgot i'm rich i'm supposed to
spend a lot of money i don't spend money
on myself why should i spend more on
other people that's not fair
[Music]
fine i'll do it fine fine i don't care
i'm getting my credit card
i'm ready what the [ __ ] was that oh my
god what's that
does that count as a laugh i think that
counts as a life
[Laughter]
all right let's start donating actually
let's let's check if anyone's live on
youtube
i mean i'm uh i'm a youtuber all right
what's happening
all right i'll donate to blitz because
he's got the pewdiepie skin at night
right
thank you so very much for your support
i hope you continue to enjoy your
priority and sub games
your priority in uh custom games your
access to exclusive channels on the
discord server your access to 22
exclusive remotes this guy is salesman
thank you so much
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's funny uh pewdiepie
this thing's a real pewdiepie is it nah
it can't be the real pewdiepie
well pewdiepie thank you so very much
for the
biggest super chat of the stream coming
through with the tactical super chat
100 buckaroos or not even
bro so that's like over 100 no that's
pounds bro that's even more
generous nice pewdiepie skin question
mark
um oh god what a face
i'm leaving at cringe dude all right
let's keep going
my solution to socially distant
[Music]
halloween
that's kind of cool that's not funny
though i'm not laughing at least someone
is having fun during quarantine
oh he's coming around this way i think
duke's getting
you're tired all my chicken boys
ridin
[Laughter]
she's like
that's so cute i'm not even mad now i
have my money ready
oh there's one guy watching this guy i
like that
people were mad i said it was a waste of
money last time
maybe i am cheating because this hurts
me it hurts
there's no one there now i know how you
guys feel hey maybe this is good for me
a humbling experience huh
we'll go back and see if he figures it
out later let's watch another video
my sister went to paris and saw sean
connery taking pictures with all these
people
she muscled away and asked for a photo
oh please it wasn't sean connery this
man had been taking pictures with his
family
[Laughter]
oh this is great now i can actually live
he's still just there all right
oh there it is there it is
[Music]
how could it be possible that he had a
verified account he's still speculating
because it's the same account same uh
avatar i told you he's a fan of the
beard maybe that's what it was
the beard came back i love just
confusing people
i think i need to go to twitch hey look
there's brad again
savage's hitting himself now he's like
he hasn't paid me
but he's paying his previous
1692 a little the official pewdiepie
is the afk nothing no reaction
nothing no one in the chat but because
of twitch seem to have like a certain
theme going on oh this is the same one
from last time
hey he grew in viewers good friend
what the [ __ ]
uh yo pewdiepie are you there is that
you
yes is that holy sh thank you what the
[ __ ]
oh my god i wanted to say thank you
um i commented on your video but it got
buried obviously
it might be him again it could be it
probably is
honestly if i had to guess yo if you're
there thank you
i want to say thank you before i mean i
did in the video but i mean i wanted to
thank you directly if you're here thank
you
that's all right you're thinking awesome
no no no i cannot
like can thank you enough dude it's
nothing to think about
ah check out wolfie so wholesome
all right back to the laughs god damn it
so true if you want us to paint your
house you gotta buy us yellow paint
i want my house to be gray though you
don't need yellow
we're not painting anything until you
get us yellow paint
epsom printers if so epsilon painters we
cannot paint anything
unless we got more scion whatever the
god damn it good meme all right so
clearly it's worth donating like the
ones that are very little viewers
do i need to show someone that i am
innocent oh they can't seem
that's cool i don't care oh my god what
is that
is that the anime filter
it works for dogs that's so cool
oh my god that's amazing all right
please tell me this one shows up there
it is nice beard
he's acting chefs on me wait wait a
minute
wait a minute stop no way that's not
real pewdiepie that's not a real
donation
what is knowing something ain't right
jeez
listen are you a troller or are you
pewdiepie is it pewds no way
wait i don't know somebody called
pewdiepie donated 168 dollars
dude no way come on guys
[Music]
i can't see anything same twitch name
what if it's beautiful then write in
chat
it's pure it's pid pi it's not even
pewdiepie
no i straight yeah i was joking
if only real if the money's in your bank
yeah
yeah it's real money but it can just
refund it oh my god
all right this is the last one wait why
would i click on his name
yeah it takes me to pull the panel
because i can't create it
no way really okay that's saved me 169.
nice
no stop dude when i when i click on his
name when i click on the name no stop
dude i'll actually
no way no way dude why is it why doesn't
it say it's verified though when i click
on his name it takes me to pewdiepie and
it's created 2011. no way somebody
created that account to troll back then
oh my god no way
oh this is too funny okay if they make
me laugh [ __ ] it why not
dude 69 no
no no that does not count that does not
count that does not count
that does not count all right i get
three strikes oh my god this [ __ ]
clip yeah i
i didn't realize he had magnets okay i
know what magnets are i know what
magnets are oh sorry
i definitely know what magnets are trust
me oh oh that's gonna hurt
oh no why
those legs are
that does not count either because uh i
say so it's been six months since i put
this on a welder at work no one has said
anything it's a magnet with sharpie on
it
[Laughter]
oh that's brilliant i'm using just that
on the welder please thank you
that's funny right all right fine there
it is
hey red hello i'm back pewdiepie just
tipped
168.99 are you
serious no not this again thank you so
much
i will eat five of these in one bite if
so if it is actually pewdiepie
oh my god
okay last time
um he just tipped again thank you so
much
thank you you're not getting my message
learning french menu
murmur
a right blackberry murmurs to the wall
immune
[Music]
good name looks nice
what happens i'm just confusing people
is that a misclick
no was that a misclick um yo
felix what the hell
she knows me that's great i hope
i was that a misclick like i can refund
it
thank you so much i really appreciate it
what the hell i don't even
oh she doesn't know who i she you have
to write felix that's funny she just
know i'm pewdiepie i was like wait she
knows
my name is felix i can refund it but
dude
what clicked again no wait no miss
what
i'm so confused i'm literally just doing
i'm just making a curse texture pack
[Music]
that's all i think whoops clicked again
oh
god oh thank you i really appreciate it
but
what the hell there's no way no i don't
believe no oh
no no no this is cracking me up more
than the actual part it was that's right
god no that does not count i just
stopped
what the [ __ ] is happening that is some
confusing ass faces dude
squirrel gets frozen in time
[Music]
is he scared oh i feel so bad
all right let's do the last donation
i'll do a big one this looks like
quality i like this
i'm giving him birthday cheers what did
i just see
what the [ __ ]
happy birthday man hope you have a great
one wait
he's not counting how much money it is
oh my god
maybe that was a mistake pewdiepie thank
you so much
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] i could help you with
a refund
yes one more zero wait how much did i
give him
or did you mean to give it to me
sure i meant it hopefully some
redemption
i know it's not mr b's money but it's
not always about the money either so
that's something to think about i
i had a lot of fun that was cool thank
you if you enjoyed
subscribe i'll do more your life you
donate speaking of donate
this month's charity is going to towards
mental health
all the member money is going to charity
it seems like everyone forgot that when
they got mad at me for not doing enough
to twitch streamers just like come on
uh but i i do want to give a shout out
to everyone that's a member and for
supporting the channel thank you
uh and yeah
[Music]